- This is the opposite of turning
me on right now.
(laughing)
Like--
- You know, you haven't tasted
it yet so maybe it'll turn you on.
- Oh yeah, maybe I'll eat it
and I'll just be like oh yeah,
I wanna hit right now.
(upbeat music)
- We are gonna make
aphrodisiac sandwiches.
I wish Erica would make me food
at any point in time.
- Oh, ditto.
- Yeah, I kind of believe in
aphrodisiacs, I guess?
- Oh my god, there is goat cheese.
Goat cheese should be on everything.
- It's a red pepper, looks
hot and I think helps
the removal of clothes.
- We have chocolate which I'm just
gonna eat one right now 'cause
chocolate's good.
- She's about the chocolate life.
- We got some bananas, which I don't know
if they're an aphrodisiac,
but they're phallic.
- I don't know, peppers?
- Peppers.
- Maybe to like spice things up.
Don't make me a bad sandwich though.
- I'm gonna make you a good-ass sandwich.
- I'm starting with the bananas because
I think that bananas and chocolate
go really well together.
- You're not gonna put like something,
like I'm gonna put the avocado down
'cause that would stick.
- [Katie] Now I'm a little going off
the beaten path here.
- My sandwich is something
you could probably like
you're gonna be able to purchase.
Like somewhere in one of
these like uppity cafes.
- Worst case scenario,
they're all aphrodisiacs
and like if I put more of them on,
it's probably not gonna be a bad thing.
- She has mashed up bananas
and mixing avocado into it.
- Like looking at it makes me want
to throw up right now.
I mean, like I'll eat it because
of love or whatever.
- My sandwich has a lot of things on it
because there are a lot of components
to a relationship.
- I'm gonna name it
Bananas About You.
- I'll name my sandwich,
it's gotta be sexual?
- I'm gonna call it a Bae-wich
'cause this my bae.
- I'm your bae.
- So this is The Love Boat.
- Ready for your love boat, let's go.
- Time to dock.
(sexy music)
That was dirty, I'm sorry.
- It's good though.
- It's not, I mean, like it's not bad.
- Oh my god, that bite
was bread and banana
so it was fine.
- It's fine.
- Yeah, you like it?
- Mm hmm.
- Yeah, great.
- I've never been more attractive
to you right now.
- Not necessarily too horny.
- Right, I feel like if
I had more chocolate,
which I've been eating this whole time,
maybe, like it could happen.
- If it were a slice of pizza, for sure.